- My name's Luis, and I
really like the word curvy.
It's a great word used to
describe both women and roads,
but it doesn't really apply to men.
So I went to the streets
of Hollywood to find out,
what is the male equivalent
to the word curvy?
What do you think about the word curvy?
- I like it. I like it.
- Thick girls are my favorite girls,
so I love the word.
- I actually thought we were
talking about an art project.
- When you say curvy,
what do you mean when you're
describing someone as curvy?
- I think that there are negative
and positive interpretations of the word.
When I hear it it's like voluptuous.
I also don't think voluptuous
is a negative word.
- It just sends a good
message to younger women,
that you don't have to
be a twig to be big,
or to be influential, you can be curvy.
- I think always put
some meat on that bone,
'cause I'ma eat it, eat it.
- When we're talking about the word curvy,
do you attach that word
to a certain gender?
- I feel like it's not as common
to describe men in that way.
- I would never call a dude curvy.
- None can be curvy.
- I just think more to love
is what we should use for men.
- I guess I would say
like he's a big dude,
is what I would say.
- Like a dude that got ass.
Like a dude that got ass.
- Stocky or bulky.
- Well rounded, well grounded.
- The point is, whatever
your body type is,
just be happy with it, look in the mirror,
and say I love who I am,
and like that Christina Aguilera song,
I'm beautiful in every single way.
- So it's just about owning your body.
- Totally, and letting
me own your body too.
Body too.